I got robbed like that outside uh the uh
whatever the Atlanta whatever Dome it
was no for um what's it called Peach
Bowl tickets like these kids were so
clever dude what they did was we were
looking for tickets me and a friend of
mine and they had a folded piece of
paper like this and they go here's the
tickets right and we took it and you
look and the tickets are there like
they're they're Peach Bowl tickets yeah
like legit ones and you're like okay
then they take it back and they're like
if you want the ticket so then you give
them the cash and then they hand the
thing back in the open and there's two
pink slips and the guys are just gone
the sleight of hand there's very sleight
of hand bro I mean it's so fast